[Music]
hey guys it's obscene right now I'm in
New York and I just got out of the
Microsoft event where they announced a
bunch of new products their service line
I'm such a huge fan of surface
I was really excited to be here and to
get to experience this in person and I
am sitting on a throne of surface to
surface pro 782 Silver's pro packs and
who service laptop three they also
announced in surface earbuds and they
even gave us a sneak peek of two things
that won't be out until 2020 it's the
surface duo and a surface meu basically
taking that foldable concept and having
two screens so you'll be able to run one
app on the left one app on the right you
can also use one app in both windows the
reason they did announce this ahead of
time for it to be released next year is
the developers will have time to
actually make things to the one it is
out you'll be able to use
so let's go walk around and see we can
see
[Music]
we've got some secret fun happening we
are now in the room we have everything
they announce today it's over here
starting with the surface pro X with
this incredible secret hidden surface
pen we've got the surface pro 7 and the
new surface laptop threes and this is
the new sandstone color most laptops
that are designed this way they kind of
have like a little finger groove so that
when you go like this to pick it up
there's a place to put your fingers just
a small tiny little ledge here and you
lift it up
I love sperry fast seamless it was very
seamless this is the 13 inch this is a
15 inch leave it is a feel it actually
feels pretty good it's pretty light like
could I hold it like this if I were oh
yeah
oh my keys away also has USB see thank
you headphone jack and a regular USB a
porch the surface laptop 3 is actually
twice as fast with the previous
generation and you can choose from 2
different keyboard finishes it has a 20%
larger trackpad a fast-charging but it
also has a removable hard drive so this
is really great for upgrading but also
for security purposes hey do you even
hear me typing yeah I have a very
aggressive type oh you share hotel rooms
she's like you gotta stop it
I mean its aggressive but this is pretty
quiet yeah this isn't bad at all like in
kids I just I'm really quiet oh here's
our surface pro 7 I love the surface
line they're just so cool this is the
little icy blue color
ice ice blue it's ice look I'm I think I
see blue is something that they should
think about for next year
that looks this is a poppy bread it's a
nice red color it's not too bright but
it's also a nice and muted tone here the
surface pro 7 comes in a platinum in a
matte black for the 12 point 3 inch
display you could choose from an i3 and
i5 and i7 processor for 8 or 16 gigs of
memory storage options our solid state
drives 128 256 512 or a terabyte you can
get up to ten and a half hours of
battery life you can charge your surface
pro 7 to 80% in just over an hour the
front-facing camera will shoot 1080p HD
video with a 5 megapixel sensor the
rear-facing is an 8 megapixel sensor and
you could also shoot 1080 it has USB a
USB C and a 3.5 millimeter headphone
jack it also has a mini DisplayPort
there's a micro SD card reader which is
pretty awesome and it's also compatible
with a surface dial this one has the
poppy red keyboard with the matching it
poppy red pen poppy red dark Mouse
anyone I just love it I love the design
of this it's so cool it's like a slap
bracelet so the pro-x was one of the
things that I was most looking forward
to checking out because it has one of
the more newer designs so the surface
pen is just hidden so right here I kept
calling you like a garage or like a
pencil box this is magnetic it also
charges any time it is connected to its
little garage and as soon as you take it
out it switches into the mode where you
can use the pen this is so funny it's
the full screen snip and there it is I
just took the full screen snip hello
Joan
this is one of their thinnest designs
ever it's only seven point three
millimeters it also features a 13 inch
edge to edge display it'll give you all
day battery life which they said is
about 13 hours and it's fast charging
which should get you about an 80% charge
within an hour it can be always
connected if you choose to connect it to
LTE but again one of my favorite things
about the pro-x
is even safely store and charge your
surface pen right here it has two USB
seaports and uses window hello
authentication in the front-facing
camera that's really my best work one of
the things that they were talking about
is fast charging which is great because
I feel like a lot of times it does take
a little bit longer to charge up a
laptop but they said you can get about
80 percent charge within an hour maybe
even under an hour depending upon which
surface were using these are the new
surface earbuds so it's really cool
because this is basically made to work
seamlessly with office products it'll
also do live transcription so if you're
speaking in English like I am now I
don't know any other languages so this
can automatically translate on the fly
one of my favorite things that someone
said on Twitter was they gotta look like
pop sockets little minis well guys this
is just a first look at some of the new
stuff that Microsoft announced I'm
looking forward to getting some review
units I'm so excited to get a chance to
test some of these things out so stay
tuned and look for some more videos
coming up let me know what you guys
think which one was your favorite and
what do you guys most looking forward to
I know you're probably looking forward
to what's coming out in 2020 the neo and
the duo the Pro X I think is something
that I'm looking forward to trying out
the most so that's it I'll see you guys
later and that's the end of the video
now
[Music]